Justin Jones, who
infamously was expelled from his seat
by his Republican colleagues
after a heated debate on gun
reform before eventually being reinstated
has been silenced by Republican
lawmakers yet again
during a special session
yesterday on public safety measures.
In the aftermath
of that deadly national school
shooting that killed
six people, including three children.
Representative Jones
was accused of being, quote, off topic
and was reprimanded
based on newly imposed rules
that were set
by the Republican supermajority.
Joining me now is Democratic State
Representative Justin Jones.
And thank you for being here.
You were ruled out of order.
Can you just walk us through
what happened
and what it was that you said
that was deemed off topic
Yes. Caitlyn.
Well, thank you so much for having me.
Today is a very sad day for Tennessee
because we just adjourn
our special session,
not returning until January
without passing
any common
sense gun laws
and once again, silencing
voices of dissent.
Yesterday, I was silenced
in an unprecedented
move to enact new House rules
that would stop me from speaking
for the rest of the day.
Because I was
talking about the need of my district
for more mental health
support, more counselors,
not more armed
guards and guns in our schools.
And for that,
the speaker said I was off
topic and said that I was out of order
and I could not speak
for the rest of the day
and that if I was
ruled out of order again,
I wouldn't be able to speak
for three days
and the next
events would be indefinitely.
So this is what we're seeing happening
under these new House rules.
Being weaponized
to silence voices of dissent,
as well as to criminalize
mothers who are in committee
holding up paper signs
who were dragged out
by troopers
for exercising
their First Amendment right
So the special session
is on public safety.
You're bringing up things
that you believe
would increase public safety,
and you were therefore
therefore ruled out of order.
Is that right?
That's correct.
I've voiced
the concerns of my district district 52
in Tennessee
who said that
what would make us feel safe
will help
in this time of crisis
because of the continual
occurrence of mass shootings
and gun violence in our state
and in our nation.
And I was not even able
to voice those concerns
and I think that's very unfortunate
because we are supposed to be
a deliberative body, a legislative body.
I'm a representative of my district,
and I can't even speak for my district.
The Speaker Gavel me off topic
and so I couldn't
speak for the rest of the day.
But what he was really trying to stop
Caitlin was a motion
for no confidence
that I had told him
I was going to make at the end of session
for Under New Business to call a no vote
a vote of no confidence in his leadership
because of his failure as speaker.
Attacking constitutional rights,
silencing the voices of Tennesseans.
Refusing to take up seriously
the issue of gun violence.
And he wanted to shut that down.
So you're saying he just did it
because he was
mainly worried
that you were going to call
a no confidence vote for him.
He was
even today before we adjourned session.
Once again,
I rose my hand and thought recognition
to make the motion to vote.
No confidence
in the speaker of the House of Tennessee,
Cameron Sexton.
And he chose to ignore me
and to go to one of his members
to merely call the adjournment vote.
And if he was confident his leadership
Caitlin, he would take the vote.
But what we're seeing
is a speaker who is so fragile
and so afraid of being held accountable
that even his own Republican
members are frustrated with
how he's led Tennessee.
You saw what happened on April 6th
when we were expelled.
You saw what happened there.
A special session
with mothers
whose children were involved
in shooting
and gun violence at their school
being dragged out of committee.
I mean, the House in Tennessee
is out of order.
The speaker is out of order.
He should resign.
But if he won't resign,
I'll be back in January to call for a
no confidence vote in his leadership.
Right.
Does your
whole point of this
special session was to pursue
these measures?
You don't believe
anything of substance has passed.
And now
we'll see what January looks like.
Representative Justin Jones
thank you again for joining us
here tonight on The Source.
Thank you so much, Caitlin.